[Musique]
vous l'avez deviné notre ca ce soir
diane bérard nicolas duvernois bonsoir
bonsoir
diane jason kenney a t-il raison de dire
que la pensée unique des élites
politiques du québec contre des
exportations de pétrole ne reflète pas
ce que pense la majorité des québécois
sur le pétrole
mais en fait oui ils ont raison les deux
tiers des québécois disent préférer le
pétrole albertain à tous les autres
pétrole mais faut faire attention je
peut préférer l'agneau au boeuf mais
aimer encore mieux les repos les jettent
à rien et est en fait de retirer la
viande de mon alimentation
donc quand on dispose on dit ça on n'a
pas tout dit on a juste dit qu'on
préfère le pétrole albertain si tout
maintenant est ce qu'on dit est ce que
les québécois disent massivement il faut
exporter davantage de pétrole albertain
j'ai pas vu la preuve de ça dans aucun
sondage hockey parce que vous en pensez
quoi nicolas
mas la question n'allait pas jusqu'à la
la question était si on préfère le
pétrole albertain et oui effectivement
bonne majorité de la population le
préfère après si on veut résultat rien
végétaliens ou autre ça c'est un autre
sujet cependant je crois qu'on
sous-estimé l'importance du pétrole pour
le canada donc par conséquent qu'on le
veuille ou pas pour le québec si c'est
plus de 400000 emplois directs ces 10
milliards de recettes fiscales pour un
pays qui est endetté par dessus la tête
avec une inflation qui ne cesse
d'augmenter et surtout avec l'invasion
de l'ukraine qui a foutu le bordel dans
dans tout ce qui est l'industrie
l'univers des énergies à droite à gauche
sur la planète ben je crois que le
timing est parfait sincèrement pour
jason kenny pour avoir cette discussion
cependant s'il arrive ici en voulant
donner des leçons et puis en dix ans qui
a appris la langue de molière qui a été
au berceau pour pouvoir convaincre le
québec je crois que sa bonne stratégie
la stratégie elle est purement
financière purement économique pur
montage est tristement c'est parce que
c'est pas mon rêve bien entendu il faut
tout faire pour faire cette transition
et que vertes le plus rapidement
possible mais pour la financer et en
attendant eh bien on a le pétrole
canadien donc le pétrole canadien est
une source de richesse nique
oui absolument écouter encore une fois
c'est parce que je veux dire en quelque
sorte parce que mon coeur me dit bien
entendu que l'environnement c'est la
priorité ultime cependant pour se rendre
à
rêves là qu'on veut il va falloir
continuer encore un peu à utiliser ce
fameux vol donkey kong à y aller est-ce
qu'on est hypocrite de ne pas compte
tenu des besoins de pétrole que nous
avons toujours de dire non on n'en veut
pas on veut pas de pipeline on veut pas
d'oléoducs oui on achète notre pétrole
au canada puis aux états unis mais
on veut des réductions de gaz à effet de
serre l'alberta doit faire son travail
diane
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie qui
avaient toujours jusqu'à présent défendu
les pétrolières étaient très claires
dans son dernier rapport à partir de 22
elle recommande de ne plus autoriser
aucun nouveau projet d'exploration et
d'extraction pétrolière donc il faut
cesser l'exploration pétrolière donc là
c'est un message qui vient directement
de l'agencé - afin de l'énergie non
c'est pas possible
alors d'un côté on a baissé les
émissions de gaz à effet serre par baril
donc les pétrolières de l'ouest ont fait
leur travail est long d'un c'est le
baril et moins polluante hausse et une
problème l'intensité moins polluante
mais pourquoi ils font ça pour pouvoir
augmenter l'offre donc oui c'est marrant
ça donne quoi de baisser les émissions
gaz un fêtard si de l'autre côté on
continue qui on veut produire de plus en
plus qui on veut exporter donc l' agence
internationale de l'énergie a été clair
je n'ai plus de nouvelles explorations
donc ça devrait avoir un message clair
pour thème de 2005 pour terre-neuve pour
le projet de terre-neuve ça ça va être
un autre lorsqu'on ces mois ci vont dire
oui ou non de 2005 à 2010 9 l'intensité
a baissé de 20% des densités carbone du
pétrole mais là où elle est la
production a tellement augmenté que les
émissions ont augmenté de 137 % mais
voilà donc c'est ce qui est hypocrite
c'est pas de ces pots notre attitude
c'est d'un côté travailler sur labase
intense paix pour pouvoir produire
davantage est-ce que c'est du pétrole
éthique le pétrole de l'alberta nicolas
est ce que c'est du pétrole éthique
comme le dit jason kenney
ouais disons que la face et jouer avec
les mots à son meilleur exemple oui ça
l'est par définition c'est tout aussi et
même plus polluants mais c'est éthique
donc en quoi ces trois coups de poing
mais avec une main qu'un
baum a dit qu on me connaît mais en quoi
c'est éthique
mais les pays producteurs de pétrole
au moyen orient sont extrêmement
flexible avec tout ce qui touche les
droits humains ici on a des standards on
va se le dire quand même beaucoup plus
haut et donc je crois que c'est chez de
ce qui fait référence et c'est à ce que
fait référence diane c'est exactement ça
l'expression pétrole était qui ont été
inventés en 2011 par un stratège du de
l'alliance démocratique
donc ça allait s'appeler et écho aux
ailes puis on faisait référence au fait
que le pétrole canadien est produit dans
une démocratie donc qui ne servaient pas
à financer un régime totalitaire mais
aujourd'hui réutiliser cette expression
là on essaie de mélanger un peu éthique
et responsable donc traduit par une
démocratie mais dans des conditions qui
a fait que l'environnement alors on joue
sur les mots et c'est pas le même la
même signification qu'en 2011
aujourd'hui quand on parle de titre on
ajoute les variables environnementales
on change de premier ministre jason
kenney on s'en va d'oxford en ontario
d'oxford veut réduire la paperasse pour
accélérer l'approbation de projets de
construction de propriété c'est sa
solution pour calmer la frénésie
immobilière
alimentée l'offre de propriétés nicolas
vous en pensez quoi mais c'est surtout
les points qu'ils utilisent ou les
laisse ou point qu'ils utilisent pour
pour alimenter l'offre moi j'adore ça
explique obliger les fonctionnaires à
accélérer dans leurs démarches punir les
municipalités qui près de 400 ans pour
te dire si tu peux avoir de bord des
fenêtres bleu ou beige dans la rue
sincèrement à toronto un changement de
zonage à 39,25 moi même cinq mois et a
même plus à l'aise quand le quartier
change de nouveau à un pouce pendant ce
temps là et puis là il ya quelqu'un qui
réfléchit si elle renaître une fête sur
le côté de la maison pas un moment donné
faut accélérer la au moi ça ne fait pas
ça m'a fait plaisir je suis pas mon
favori mais au moins un aligot gogo dans
la villa c'est pas votre favori mais
quelques et l'appui
dionne moi j'ai envie de dire neuf tirs
et une expression d'une vieille pub je
dirais whaou les mateurs ok donc à
quelque part l'idée c'est pas d'accepter
des projets immobiliers c'est de bâtir
des milieux de vie or j'ai un peu peur
que le mieux soit l'ennemi du bien mais
quelque part à force d'accélérer c'est
pas accélérer les projets qu'il faut
faire c'est s'ouvrir l'esprit à
l'innovation est acceptée ce qui était
dans le rapport parce qu'il y avait un
comité d'experts qui va faire un rapport
présenté à d'oxford il y avait une des
recommandations dans ce qui était
d'accepter toutes les unités
d'habitation autres les unités
d'habitation etc soit les résidents
jardin le but est d'arrêter que ce
montant parce qu'on est rendu à un
million à peu près le prix moyen dans le
grand toronto ben helli décès de
densifier alors la led au dr otto une
très faible densification par rapport
aux grandes métropoles donc on peut
densifier faire de la densification
doses donc au lieu d'accélérer les
projets oui il faut enlever la
bureaucratie mais faut surtout s'ouvrir
l'esprit à d'autres formes d'habitation
densifier demain sans doute et ça doit
nous inspirer
de ce côté ci de la rivière des
outaouais nicolas
oui parce que l'idée n'était pas
d'accélérer la construction c'était
d'accélérer le processus pour construire
parce que c'était tout aussi compliqué
de construire une cité verte qu'une
maison à 10 millions c'est ça le
problème c'est la lourdeur
administrative pour ne serait-ce qu elle
allait pourrait ne déboucher pas où
acheter le pen comment sait-on projet
est donc oui il faut tout ce qui
facilite la vie du citoyen moi je suis
d'accord site wenn man comme on dit
aujourd'hui
vient d'intervenir pas non plus quoi
faciliter la vie des citoyens
mais pas donné carte blanche comprend
matar immobilier voilà mais j'ai jamais
vu ça c'est comme si nous les italiens
le seul
risque d'accord vous n'êtes pas d'accord
vous vous dites à peu près la même chose
mais en des termes différents d'accord
je vois là d'accord je vous souhaite une
bonne soirée en partie raison mercredi
prochain
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit